a night game under the lights down at
leighton orient
in the hour before kickoff the bars in
this corner of east london are full
a ritual that currently stops before
they take their seats i go to rugby
quite a lot we have beer in the stands
you know we go down and come back we're
allowed to do it we behave ourselves why
wouldn't we behave ourselves at football
there's time before and after a game to
have a drink so there's no need to
really drink whilst you're watching the
game
swapping soft drinks for a pint in the
stands is an idea that could well be
trialled here in league two and the club
really want to do it i would like to
think it would be given perhaps from
january to the end of the season to to
understand it in warmer months as well
as in the colder
cold tuesday nights and then i think the
idea was that we we may do it in trial
in certain areas to start with if there
was
fans getting carried away throwing lager
in the air at a goal
what happens i think the lager throwing
is i've experienced it at venues when
watching sort of england play it's not
the best experience and we'll be trying
to find ways that that experience isn't
repeated
the police point to this the euro 2020
final at wembley which descended into
chaos fueled by excessive drinking
it may have been something of a one-off
event but the police have big
reservations about relaxing the rules
it's an unnecessary step you know people
can have a drink in the grounds at the
concourse unlike scotland where it's
banned in its entirety and just at the
moment we've seen increases levels of
violence increase in hate crime it is an
unnecessary risk to take on one that i
think actually be really foolish at this
time
you'd perhaps think that the stewards
who manage the crowds in the stands
might agree
but not all of them
i think a good trial give us what six
weeks yeah until the end of the season
see how it goes yeah and if he's
successful then next season
let every club do it
layton orients already one step ahead of
another proposal to ban gambling firms
from sponsoring club shirts
it's a charity on their shirt this year
paid for by england captain harry kane
who once used to play here
the alcohol trial is just one part of
this fan-led review and whether it works
or not putting supporters at the front
and center of the decisions made in
football is something that is long
overdue
however many supporters think it's time
to allow them to drink in the stands
it's the way the minority behave that's
always the problem
and will dictate whether or not this
trial is a success
tom parmenter sky news east london